y
[Música]
bienvenidos a la emisión de los
observadores de france 24 el ejército
estadounidense y sus aliados salieron de
afganistán a finales del mes de agosto
evacuaron decenas de miles de afganos
pero dejaron atrás de ellos una nación
entera en las manos del talibán su
portavoz afirma que cambiaron y que
sería el talibán 2.0 más tolerante que
durante su brutal régimen de los años 90
pero realmente cambiaron y son
verdaderamente un grupo uniforme las
fuerzas especiales que tomaron el
control del aeropuerto de kabul
pertenecen a la poderosa red haqqani al
mismo tiempo sus rivales los duran y
exhibieron las armas que tomaron de su
base de kandahar en el sur del país
los haqqani están establecidos en el
este muy cerca de la frontera con
pakistán mientras que los dos ran y
fundadores del talibán se encuentran en
el sur y en el sureste del país pero qué
ha pasado con los ciudadanos afganos del
común
como es la vida bajo la dominación de
los talibanes hablamos con nuestros
observadores afganos en los cuatro
rincones de ese país
los salarios no tienen uniforme pero son
fáciles de reconocer tienen el pelo
largo sucio y una barba larga y fusiles
cuando alguien les habla ellos dicen que
no conocen la ciudad por la manera en la
que hablan se visten y se comportan es
claro que la mayoría de ellos nunca
había estado en una ciudad hasta ahora
los talibanes actúan como si todavía
vivieran en las montañas van a la casa
de las personas en grupo entre 5 y 10 y
esperan que la gente los alimenten como
lo hacían en los pueblos remotos de las
montañas esa es la tradición en los
pueblos pero así no es como se comportan
las personas en las ciudades de
afganistán
su comportamiento es muy violento
intimidan a las personas en la calle
[Música]
le piden a la gente que los lleve en el
carro comen en la casa de las personas o
les piden dinero para alimentarse
los talibanes llevaron a cabo
investigaciones puntuales para encontrar
militantes no lo anunciaron oficialmente
lo hacen en secreto para evitar llamar
la atención tienen lista de personas que
trabajan con extranjeros o que hacían
voluntariado con activistas
los talibanes mataron a una de mis
colegas ella era militante por los
derechos de las mujeres y enfermeras
ellos llegaron a su casa y le dispararon
en la frente las mujeres afganas se
sienten particularmente
amenazadas aunque el talibán afirmó que
serían libres de estudiar o trabajar
pero en sus ciudades nuestros
observadores afirman que el talibán le
pidió a las mujeres que se quedaran en
casa las mujeres en particular las más
jóvenes de las ciudades que nunca
conocieron la vida bajo el talibán han
defendido sus derechos
hablamos con una de ellas que ayudó a
organizar una manifestación en la
capital los talibanes fueron muy
violentos nos golpearon con cables de
hierro y con la culata de sus fusiles
[Aplausos]
dispararon al aire para detener la
manifestación
nosotras las mujeres no somos ingenuos
sabemos lo que el talibán nos puede
hacer pero cuando estamos juntas nos
sentimos más fuertes no teníamos miedo
cuando nos estaban golpeando seguiremos
nuestras protestas hasta que seamos
libres
el talibán a veces es considerado como
una entidad única con una política común
compartida pero en realidad este grupo
está compuesto por diferentes facciones
que podrían volver a asumir a afganistán
en la guerra moctar guay afi es un
periodista afgano que sigue de cerca al
taleb antes de hace muchos años y una de
las facciones del talibán es conocida
bajo el nombre de red haqqani sólo sería
euros operacionales de tema
sirajudín haqqani es el líder de la red
haqqani
su tío cali man hakan y es el comandante
en terreno su hermano nan haqqani es la
principal figura política de la facción
los haqqani controlan la mayor parte del
este y del centro de afganistán
luciendo kabul la capital en los últimos
años los haqqanis fueron los
responsables de los ataques terroristas
y talibán en kabul y sus alrededores
pero ahora los haqqanis son responsables
de la seguridad en la capital son la
rama más extremista del talibán
la mayoría de sus miembros se
inscribieron para hacer posible
kamikazes
la otra gran facción solo durán y su
jefe es el mulá sahagún hijo del
fundador del talibán el mulá omar
los duran y controlan principalmente el
sur de afganistán y algunas partes del
oeste los 2 ramón controlan el
aeropuerto de kandahar de igual que una
gran cantidad de armas ligeras y pesadas
los duran y ahora tienen muchos
helicópteros blackhawk del aeropuerto de
kandahar
los duran y también tienen escuadrones
suicidas como estos hombres de plano a
grandes rasgos los rangers y los
haqqanis son equivalentes en términos de
capacidades militares y de recursos
económicos
incluso durante esas primeras semanas
vimos señales de que las dos facciones
se están posicionando por una lucha por
el poder la rivalidad entre las dos
tribus podría llevar a más combates en
afganistán entonces a una guerra civil
entre esas dos facciones del talibán
cuando el talibán tomó el control de
kabul los jacales se tomaron todas las
oficinas estratégicas militares y de
inteligencia
no dejaron que otras facciones talibanas
ingresarán al ministerio de defensa al
ministerio del interior puesto de kabul
y otros edificios importantes
hay un riesgo de que el talibán no tenga
la capacidad para crear la autovía
islámica que le prometió a sus
seguidores
y de que sus combatientes se unen a
facciones más extremistas como el grupo
estado islámico
nos mantenemos en contacto con nuestros
observadores en afganistán para seguir
la evolución de la situación en las
próximas semanas y meses en ese país si
usted quiere comunicarse con nuestra
redacción todos los datos de contacto
aparecen en sus pantallas nos vemos en
la próxima emisión de los observadores
de france 24 hasta entonces